[Music]
guys John
real rejects it's Monday and guess what
Jim from the office is in a new movie
John Krasinski is back with a new
directorial effort he also punched up
the script on this it looks like a
horror movie that's exciting to me so
let's jump into this
[Music]
alright damn it
child
[Music]
jigsaw
[Music]
it's a bad situation oh man oh man this
is a pretty intense trailer I gotta say
well done John Krasinski and company
this is also the team it's not they're
not making a big deal out of hit on this
trailer anyway but this is also from
Platinum Dunes in light of that I'm
happy to see that Platinum Dunes is
doing more original stuff I mean they're
pretty well known for making some of the
big horror remakes I'm Erin Elm Street
Friday the 13th Texas Chainsaw The
Hitcher the Amityville Horror and
they've done some other original stuff
it just doesn't seem to be as
in-your-face or they don't seem to be as
in-your-face about it so something like
this I'm kind of excited to see them
take on and especially I think their
relationship with blue house has kind of
rubbed off nicely they collaborated on
the purge and some other things so um
you know III root for Platinum Dunes in
a way I mean they always bring a certain
element of polish and of all of Michael
Bay's being dunes is the one that I kind
of look to for the occasional hit the
occasional thing I actually enjoy
because I like some of those movies I
like the Texas Chainsaw a remake I like
to Friday remake pretty well I did not
like Elm Street at all that's neither
here nor there this movie looks really
cool though I'm kind of fascinated by
the friendship between John Krasinski
and Michael Bay but there you have it
this trailer looked really cool really
intense I mean as a director I'm excited
to see John Krasinski to extend his
chops I haven't seen any of his
directorial efforts yet however I really
want to see this just based on the mood
and the look of this trailer I mean the
shots are gorgeous the mood is really
tense and I like this idea that you know
we're gonna have to avoid sound we're
gonna have to be silent because I feel
like that's certainly a challenging hook
and for a burgeoning director in this
arena I think that's gonna be a cool
thing to check out cuz the forum is
gonna have to complement this movie so
John Krasinski's definitely I have to
bring it on those terms as well the
acting all looks good I love
that there in this little ramshackle
house you know communicating via sign
language and stuff it looks like a cool
world and I like the the sense of
suspense the mystery element of what is
out there and I guess I'm kind of
conflicted having seen like that one
little hand like it's cool part of me I
guess kind of wishes I could just a
hundred percent wait until the movie to
see what this is what it looks like etc
but it's only a hand it's not that big a
deal I was enjoying that sort of I have
no idea what's out there I just know
where that it's something in its
sinister I wonder why that kid turned on
that rocket and this can't be new for
him it seems just like an odd choice but
who knows so yeah I don't know it's a
pretty straightforward trailer only a
couple moments of dialogue but it looks
like a really tense movie it looks like
they're probably gonna be some really
good performances in you know John
Krasinski's going out of his way to show
that he doesn't have to be funny and
charming all the time and good for him
live in the post-apocalypse world where
life is joyless I want to see a future
movie about an apocalyptic scenario that
actually makes things kind of like kooky
instead of only bleak there's got to be
just like a silly dystopia I guess
idiocracy kind of cornered the market on
that yeah this looks like it has plenty
of mood and tone so I'm excited to see
it I think it's coming out in April and
here's hoping Paramount actually
releases this one this movie looks
really cool though just the world
atmosphere I like a horror movie that
takes place in a sort of desolate area
where part of the mystery comes from
just wondering where is everybody it's
eerily deserted and I like that and also
I imagine that this is gonna be a movie
that's short on dialogue short on sound
and that's always a cool challenge to
behold and I've seen some movies that
are not very dialogue heavy that have
been really striking and really distinct
so I'm excited to see how they play with
that here how they handle that any time
we glimpse into the future or a dystopia
I also appreciate when they're a little
more close to the ground when we're not
so far in the future that everything
looks foreign like I like this deserted
farm country that they're in it's got a
lot of aura it's got a lot at mysterious
cause of Emily Blunt but it kind of
reminded me of looper it
look with a more dystopian horror tone
obviously not quite as futuristic but
you know just a vibe I got so uh yeah
what do you guys think comment in the
comments box let us know but until next
time man yeah and you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell to get updated every time reviewer
video is out - also check us out on
patreon got a bunch of exclusive content
over there TV show reactions just
started The Runaways as well as
continuing Riverdale and the flash and
arrow and Rick and Morty and all sorts
of stuff doing music video reactions
also don't forget to check us out in the
Stardust app linked in the description
box download and follow us first and as
always
choo-choo-choo choose